[Musique]
c'est une croisière culturelle
on vous parle à la fois des paysages et
surtout ce qui a inspiré ce qui a incité
les peintres ou des artistes à venir sur
ce territoire
sur cette partie du territoire pour
pouvoir après peindre ses paysages
[Musique]
on vous emmène une heure pour découvrir
en fait tout le territoire jusque à
andrésy et on s'arrête on passe le pont
lat conflent et on va jusqu'à andrésy on
s'arrête juste à lécluse et on revient
sur conflans sainte honorine c'est une
jolie balade
il ya aussi un guide conférencier mais
là on va plus parler de conflans sainte
honorine la cité de la batellerie
[Musique]
m
c'est surtout pour les personnes qui
souhaitent découvrir conflent by night
alors peut-être pas tout à fait by night
mais en tout cas avant d'aller dîner
vous montez à bord coupe de champagne ou
un soft drink ou une bière et vous avez
une jolie croisière d'une heure là c'est
on lâche prise
on se détend
[Musique]